necessarily the norm that's not yet  you're not the norm you're like  but i feel like i feel like their  marriage is better because they don't  have all these like like connect like  you know you date someone for two years  and you marry someone else right you  still have that like connection with the  last person and like how many exes come  back and like ruin marriage yeah and all  that like i feel like their marriage was  better yes because they only have each  other i get that and like i feel like it  worked better that way like when women  got married younger and like we don't  have to date for 10 years and get our  hearts broken like isn't it that's  amazing you know that yo  yeah yeah